hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt es ein rezept passend zur
fußball eben und zwar mache ich ein
fußball brot also dieses boot kann man
ganz gut machen weil zur em sales gerade
auch selber wo man kann eben ganz toll
grillen will beide grillen auch immer
ganz gerne
und dazu passt natürlich am besten
frisch gebackenen straps gebackenes brot
oder ja und es mache jetzt heute im
fußball vor
das wird zu einer art sonnen brot also
seine brötchen sonne und ich hab so was
auch schon mal in ganz groß gemacht mit
etwa 50 brötchen das ereignet sich hat
immer ganz gut wie immer ganz viele
personen zusammen hat heute sind 16
brötchen denn ich möchte er diese
fußball optik auch richtig toll behalten
ich würde sagen wir grillen ganz gerne
immer weil ich dann in der küche wenig
zu tun habe aber ehrlich sagt immer so
dass ich alles vorbereiten muss und dem
rad stars eigentlich noch das fleisch
auf den grill so gut muss ja mal gesagt
werden wäre es nicht jetzt genau die
frage die in dieser schafft keine ahnung
ich interessiere mich auch ehrlich sagt
0 für dm
ich freue mich nur weil wir dann immer
klappt sieht grad an der kamera ja ich
freue mich eigentlich immer noch weil
wir immer mit den freunden zusammen
kommen so alles andere ist egal wer
mitspielt wer gewinnt das entsetzlich
ich freue mich natürlich wenn wenn der
mannschaft gewinnt die ich toll finden
aber egal jedenfalls zeige ich es
erstmal die zutaten für den hefeteig
brauche ich einen halben würfel hefe
einen telefonisch 250 milliliter wasser
420 gramm mehl eine telefon 2 esslöffel
sonnenblumenöl und etwas schwarze
lebensmittel verpasste die schwarze
lebensmittel verpasste braucht man nicht
unbedingt ich zeige euch dann auch
später an gleicher stelle woche
jetzt gibt es zuerst einmal eine
teelöffel honig ins warme wasser da
kommt die hefe mit rein und es wird
jetzt kurz mit einem schneebesen verriet
diese mischung kommt jetzt in einer
küchenmaschine
natürlich könnt ihr den tag aber auch
mit der hand weiter kneten will ich
jetzt hier reiten ich bin zum hefeteig
ist auch immer ganz schnell gemacht
bekommt das mädel mit dazu und das öl
egal was von öl ich hab gesagt
sonnenblumenöl ich finde olivenöl passt
sie nicht so ganz gut so blum also ist
geschmacksneutral und das bringt
wirklich gut
frau elisabeth und jetzt wird der hefe
teig verknetet und zwar etwas sieben bis
acht minuten
dave teig ist jetzt fertig und ich habe
den auch jetzt mit etwas temperatur
kneten lassen und zwar hab ich denn hier
auf etwa 30 bis 35 grad eingestellt und
dann geht es nämlich gleich etwas
schneller auf ich werde jetzt gleich
dieses fußball gut zubereiten und werde
daraus 16 brote formen und jetzt muss
ich den teig erst einmal portionieren
und so wenn ich jetzt in einen teil
schwarz einfärben damit ich später diese
schwarzen teile den schwarzen flecken
aus dem fußball rausgekommen und das
kind entweder mit farbe machen oder ihr
macht einfach später das etwas einfacher
und bestreut diesen schwarzen teile nur
mit schwarzkümmel oder zum beispiel
moden damit ich den teig ist richtig
einteilen werde ich jetzt erstmal ab
natürlich wiegen ab und zwar hat dates
etwa 700 gramm
und jetzt muss ich so rechnen dass ich
später 16 teile habe da ist ein
einteiler etwa 43 gramm schwer und sechs
teile davon muss ich schwarz einfärben
also nehme ich jetzt ungefähr 242 gramm
den großen teil nämlich jetzt schon mal
und formen zu einer kugel und den kann
ich jetzt mit etwas öl bestreichen und
in dieser schüssel aufgehen lassen und
den kleinen teil werde ich jetzt erst
noch mal schwarz einfärben
dafür gebe ich mir jetzt noch mal zurück
in die küchenmaschine und gebe jetzt
etwas schwarze lebensmittel verpasste
dazu und zwar so viel dass mir der teig
eben schwarz genug ist
so sieht jetzt der dunkle teig auf den
roll ich es auch zu einer kugel zusammen
und dann gebe ich ihnen eine schüssel
assault mittwoch sonnenblumenöl langsam
bestreichen und jetzt gebe ich ihnen in
einer schüssel decken dann auch ab und
stellt ihr beiden ist einfach kurz in
den backofen den habe ich bereits auf 50
grad vorgeheizten backofen wieder
ausgemacht und jetzt ist auf etwa 30
grad oder abgekühlt und dann lasse ich
die beiden teilt aufgehen für etwa 30
bis 60 minuten
die beiden teiche sind jetzt gut
aufgegangen und jetzt muss ich die teig
portionen natürlich nochmal ein teil
das heißt den hellen tag in zehn teile
und den dunklen in sex und habe vorher
auch gesagt jeder also datei quoka bei
mir etwa 700 gramm und jetzt brauche ich
pro portion immer so etwa 42 gramm
die titel werden jetzt zu kugeln geformt
und zwar immer von außen nach innen mit
den fingern und dann in der
handinnenfläche rolle und dann erst mal
kurz auf einer bemehlten arbeitsfläche
absetzen
die
hier wird alle teig kugeln geformt jetzt
werden sie noch mit wasser bestrichen
und zwar sorgt das wasser einmal dafür
dass sie glänzen und ich möchte auch
gleich noch mal beschleunigt etwas sesam
und schwarzkümmel und dann hatten die
eben auch richtig gut dran
jetzt habe ich erst mal nötig schwarzen
bestrichen und hier habe ich jetzt
schwarzkümmel und traurig jede kugel
einmal ein
das habe ich hier einen bug kabel auf 28
cm durchmesser eingestellt und da kommen
jetzt die kugeln hinein und zwar kommt
jetzt erst eine schwarze kugel in die
mitte und so wie bei einem fußball
kommen jetzt fünf weiße felder außen rum
ihr könnt jetzt immer ein bisschen platz
zwischen lassen weil die kugeln gehen ja
noch aus
jetzt kommt jeweils hier dazwischen noch
mal ein schwarzes
da dazwischen jeweils ein weißes bild
jetzt sitzen alle drei kugeln drin und
jetzt habe ich gemerkt die vorwissen ein
bisschen zu groß weil sie jetzt auch in
den ball kam und backt könnte sie jetzt
ein bisschen enger stellen dann wird der
ball auch ein bisschen schöner und jetzt
denke ich die form noch mal ab und lass
die thai kugel nochmal für etwa eine
halbe stunde auf gehen bevor ich sie
backen so das brot ist aufgegangen und
sieht so aus und jetzt kannst du den
fachärzten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze und da wir zu etwa 35 minuten
gebacken bis die hellen brötchen so
leicht braun werden
das foto ist jetzt gebacken und ich habe
es ganz kurz abkühlen lassen
jetzt kann ich die torten form lösen und
dann das brot abdecken damit vollständig
erhalten kann
man kann jetzt natürlich auch schon warm
essen aber ich möchte es noch 2 neben
noch drei tipps zu bereiten und die
mache ich jetzt kurz in der zwischenzeit
und zeigt euch dann nochmal das brot
hier sitzt das fertige brot und ich habe
noch drei tipps dazu gemacht und zwar
habe ich hier einen paprika väter tipp
einen arcade tipp und einen hit mit
getrockneter tomate und chili und die
3ds passen wirklich perfekt dazu das
brot könnte jetzt weg sagt zum grillen
zb servieren oder ja also viel zum grill
passt echt am besten
und jetzt könnt ihr euch immer so ein
stückchen abreißen und es dann immer ein
brötchen und dann kann man das ganz gut
entweder eintippen oder einfach zum zu
den anderen beilagen mitzunehmen was ich
immer ganz witzig findet also wir hatten
bei unserer hochzeitstorte er auch eine
schwarz-weiße torte weil der borat sich
eine schwarze gewinnt und nicht mehr
weiß und haben eine schwarz-weiße
gemacht und jede zweite etage war
schwarz und dauert so ich weiß nicht was
für lebensmittel farben benutzt worden
sind
auf jeden fall hat eine welle tag gast
welche torte gegessen hat mein opa hatte
zum beispiel die schwarze torte und als
er gelacht hatte er hat ganz schwarz
blaue zähne
ich glaube das passiert aber hier nicht
weil wir hier die farben mit gebacken
haben und ja eigentlich probieren
brauche ich da nette schmecken wirklich
sehr gut
und falls ihr dieses rezept gibt's auch
noch machen will dann geht auf sallys -
block der stets noch mal für euch und
wir lassen uns jetzt das brot auch
schmecken und demokraten sind bestimmt
gleich noch was dort so also bis zum
nächsten mal